[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series is called high school
memories my name is adaa and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's topic and
andberg on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
mental health awareness the importance
of mental health mental health is just
as crucial as physical health yet it
often doesn't receive the attention it
deserves we must recognize that mental
health is a spectrum and it's essential
to understand that everyone Falls
somewhere on that Spectrum
it's okay to have struggles and it's
important to address them let's breid
the stigma and open up conversations
about mental health there are many
misconceptions surrounding mental health
for instance the idea of seeking help is
a sign of weakness in reality seeking
help is a sign of strength it's
essential to debunk these myths and
create a safe place for those person
says it started with overthinking a lot
and now they started developing anger
issues but once it went over control or
out of their control they decided to go
to a therapist when they went to the
therapist they went over a few things
they also went through some other stuff
so stuff could start getting better and
after a few month everything finally
returned back to its place so how can we
promote mental health being it starts
with self-care awareness and open
dialogue we'll discuss various
techniques such as mindfulness
medication and therapy that can help
improve mental health mindfulness
treatments have been shown to reduce
anxiety and depression there's also
evidence that mindfulness can lower
psychiatric medications influence the
brain chemicals that regulate emotion
and througho patterns they usually more
effective when combined with
Psychotherapy in some cases say
medicines can reduce symptoms so other
methods of treatment plan psychiatric
medications influence the brain
chemicals that regulate emotion and
through patterns they usually more
effective when combined with psycho
therapy in some cases medicines can
reduce symptoms or other methods of
treatment plan there are numerous
resources and organizations dedicated to
mental health support will provide a
list of these resources and tips on how
to reach them thank you for joining us
on this important journey through mental
health awareness remember it's okay not
to be okay and there's always help
available let's thank you so much for
joining us on this episode of high
school
[Music]
memories